all right this is sort of like an aside
kind of adding insult to injury type
story
uh one thing that's become clear in the
first couple months of joe biden's
presidency is that he truly doesn't seem
to care about a lot of these vanity
elements that were very important to the
former president things like
television ratings or joe biden's
signature being on the coveted relief
checks that are starting to go
out now and we know that those things
were very
very important to donald trump and yet
joe biden's first primetime national
address on thursday night during which
he announced
every adult will be eligible for a
vaccine by may 1st in all 50 states
that biden event got higher ratings and
more viewership than donald trump's
first
address as president about 18.2 million
people watched joe biden's speech on
broadcast networks
compared to donald trump's first one
which 17.7 million viewers watched about
half a million more people watched the
joe biden event than watched the donald
trump event and the best part about this
to me is that joe biden clearly doesn't
care
about any of it but it's also
particularly funny because one of donald
trump's main
campaign lines against joe biden was
there's just no energy around joe i show
up and do huge rallies and joe had 10
people in cars there
honking and of course this was by design
joe biden because of the pandemic
decided it wouldn't be responsible to do
what donald trump was doing
and that's the explanation we also know
as we
learned from the democratic primary as
much as we did from the general election
in november
that tweets and facebook posts and rally
crowds don't necessarily tell you who
actually has
more support in reality and joe biden
got millions more votes than donald
trump
but biden ends up without even caring
kind of beating donald trump at his own
game without even playing the game if
you can imagine that
and as much as we know donald trump is
upset about joe biden getting credit for
the vaccination rollout which donald
trump you might remember last week put
out a statement saying
please remember that i should get credit
for the vaccines as much as trump is
upset
that things are actually starting to
improve
finally on the virus what makes
trump really upset is that he's not
getting attention anymore and joe biden
is and as hilarious as it is that joe
biden got better ratings than trump
it's something that trump is primarily
the one who cares about
the biden administration hasn't even
talked about this fact because it really
doesn't seem biden cares about ratings
and marks so to speak
and you can tell from the reactions from
right wingers
that we looked at earlier in the show
that they are also struggling with how
to respond
some right wingers have decided to focus
in on joe biden has dementia
he seemed demented during his speech he
didn't even know where he was during the
speech during which he announced hey
guys
we're accelerating vaccinations so much
that by may 1st
every adult will be eligible for a
vaccine they couldn't they didn't want
to focus on the substance so instead
they said oh joe joe biden didn't even
know he was at the white house during
the speech
others focused on how dare joe biden
politicized the fourth of july by saying
we will probably be able to have
safe cookouts and barbecues on july 4th
others focused on how dare joe biden not
get down on his knees and pray to trump
for creating the vaccines that biden is
now rolling out
and of course earlier we said trump
really doesn't deserve any credit
for the vaccines and then other
right-wingers have focused on
fear-mongering about
joe biden expanding vaccination this
month
is a clear pretext for forcing everybody
to get vaccinated which
obviously is not going to happen
and it's not what the administration is
doing it was just
like a good simple political speech with
joe biden
communicating vaccination is improving
significantly
it will continue improving and every
aspect of that speech has the right
absolutely furious and then more people
watching it than the number of people
that watch donald trump's first address
is just kind of like a pile on
at this point but there's an interesting
story to the ratings
that goes beyond trump's obsession with
ratings when
every presidential speech was like out
of this world
wacky cartoonish for four straight years
a normal speech has actually become sort
of interesting people
wrote to me dozens of people saying you
know it wasn't that i watched the biden
speech
with you or on a network or wherever
because i expected fireworks i didn't
most people didn't even expect the
expansion of vaccination to 18 plus by
may 1st
people basically wrote to me and said i
wanted to see a president just kind of
behave normally
communicate in a normal way what is
going on and that
it might get tougher before it gets
better and joe biden even sang
if this doesn't go as well as we're
hoping for i'm going to tell you
i'm not going to lie to you and say it
all went well if it didn't go well
and there's been an absence of that in
the united states
for four years and i think that's as big
a part
of what we are seeing in terms of these
tv ratings
for for the biden event as anything else